[Music]
what was halloween like for you as a boy
growing up well for some reason i lived
kind of like a davy crockett like
existence in chicago we made everything
you made everything yeah so we made all
of our halloween costumes we made
like our bikes i never had a new bike
until i was like in college
how do you make a you made a bike out of
sticks yeah you pull like a frame out of
the lagoon and you like find some tires
and
you know you replace the inner tubes you
spray paint it all at the end and there
you've got a bike so
so like fourth of july would roll around
and even then we would make our own
fireworks
where
i know it sounds crazy but we would make
bombs every year it's not
not very pc now yeah after 9 11 and
everything to talk about making bombs
but that's what we did for [ __ ]
you're a kid you would make i mean are
you talking about like you just make
little bombs well we started out little
the younger children would make littler
bombs
take like match heads and put them in a
baby food bottle and wrap it up with uh
duct tape and then stick a wick in it
and that those are actually quite potent
devices sure i don't recommend it for
kids right now my kids are writing that
down thanks a lot well it gets worse
andy yeah we would carry like garbage
can lids as uh blast shields when we
would light them you know
i think that might have helped but uh
luckily you never had a so that was a
small bomb yeah so when you say you
graduated to bigger bombs well you know
you get older you want to like kick kick
it up a notch you're like i'm not a baby
anymore i'm not going to make baby bombs
i want to make
teenage bombs so
one year
some friends and i took a coffee can
like a large coffee can
and filled it with every kind of
flammable powder
fireworks match heads we're like does
the light on fire put it in there like
and we filled this coffee can literally
was that big
to the top you know then we got to the
top we're like okay we got to seal it
it's got to be sealed like the baby food
jar you could just screw the cap on like
how are we going to seal this and i was
like oh wait my brother's got a
soldering iron i know what to do
so i took the metal coffee can lid and
put it on there and then applied molten
metal along the edge to an explosive
yeah and all of a sudden i was down in
my basement and i'm like like shaking at
that point i'd brag so much that i knew
how to solder that i didn't want to go
back and admit defeat i was like no no
it's fine it's fine me mom i had him
having visions of my whole house
engulfed in flames yeah yeah yeah so we
finished this thing and after that kind
of scary building experience i started
to get like i started to understand the
reality of explosives
and i was like you know what guys i
think this is too big for our normal
zones blast zones like you could just do
it in your backyard or something yeah
like we i was afraid we're gonna damage
a car or like
crater the ground so bad in my backyard
that my mom would be like are you
playing with bombs again
so we're like what do we do so my big
idea was well we'll build a boat for it
so we we fashioned a wooden raft like
where did you get all this time
exactly then we organized a society
and no i don't have time to return an
email today like somehow i had time to
build a floating bomb you built a boat
yeah so we took like a big pie tin put
that on the boat put the coffee can bomb
in the boat and then somewhere i picked
up along the line probably from a world
war ii movie how to make a cigarette
timer which is like you you take a
cigarette you put a hole in it then you
put the wick in the hole you like the
cigarette when the cigarette burns down
you know after a couple minutes it it
lights the fuel that's the piece of
information that kids are writing down
because that'll
and i'm like yes
that's where i've been going wrong
i watched a lot of world war ii movies
without the kid anyway so we send it out
into the lagoon in the park near my
house and i mean i didn't have
binoculars but i had these like cheap
plastic eyeglass binoculars like you get
from a novelty shop but
so i have these on like it's not wood
hold on
the wick got wet and i'm like staring
through these things and then eventually
i was like it's not working it's not
working but now it's out in the water we
can't get to it and all of a sudden i
see
like run
we turn around we're up here in the
lagoon we're running it's like slow
motion it's like one of those moments in
your childhood you're like i can't
believe i did this
and you turn i turn behind me and i see
an inverted cone of white light
it literally lights up the entire night
in the park the whole lagoon is lit
we're like
we feel like this blast wave behind us
everyone no one even talks we're like
wetting our pants we just run away like
you know this friend goes to that house
that friend goes to this house we go
home and just lock the doors
you know mom's like what's wrong nothing
i said we're jogging
you know we're jogging and urinating at
the same time
i went out the next day and i went to
the lagoon in the daylight and saw like
the pie tin that i was sitting in was
flat like a pancake right and there's
like shards of like
you know disabused wood everywhere
anyway everything from july 4th story